great yeah yeah he stopped betting you
white mike stopped that he started he
[ __ ] he fell back he's a speaker man
you need to follow the [ __ ] back you got
to chill you need to chill out you need
to stop
going out of breath let's just go
through the events
so it started with ryan garcia
versus your boy the english language lou
campbell luke campbell ryan garcia was a
minus 640. you took luke campbell
whatever easy penkins thought you'd
learn your lesson you bought me
shoes yeah shoes shoes done received
them
that was after the knockdown he still
took the bet yeah so yeah you bought him
still waiting for the shoes
then you bet what was the next bet we
made we better
was it again it was a football game it
was a game uh
i can't remember bill's ravens
my bills i was on the bills for three
days
don't make people look at that so i'll
do it was on the bills for three days
me and steve tasker okay chill out
me and don bieby
support the bill's mafia bills beat the
[ __ ] out of the ravens they beat the
[ __ ] out of them
it wasn't really a game it wasn't kind
that's when you started texting a group
you was nervous though
the whole time yeah
yeah so i got i got a net uh old school
kyrie irving jersey coming
wanted durant you got me kyrie i guess
i'll wear his jersey
he won't be there for longer not here
but he knows
and then i won another bet and then i i
have the uh hardened jersey coming
i said you bought that you bought the
jury sent me a link it's not coming to
the end of
march that's what this that's he's in
high demand the hard drive he won the
hardened jersey for this coming to the
end of march yes
again i i ordered it i sent the links he
sent me i'm like here just
anyway so so far i've got two nuts
but but that's all set on that shirt you
said you just then i got then i got my
mars shoes coming you guys so i got
two uh two jerseys shoes yeah okay i
like shoes and jerseys yeah
this was the worst bet out of all you
were talking [ __ ] in florida about the
snake the scene
this is everything i said came to
fruition i said drew brees is garbage i
said on this podcast okay and a lot of
fans came to me that was like you don't
know sports shut the [ __ ] up well look
how you feel now
he sucks i said peyton manning you can't
say he's
he's i said he sucked and he didn't
always say so no no i said
in playoffs does he up his game or does
he uh lower he's pretty [ __ ] good he
upsets a lot of times it's not
up he's like no he does not brother rams
he he had the rams that one super bowl
they got [ __ ]
literally a lot of times the saints just
had bad luck
like i'm glad you brought up the rams uh
game because guess who [ __ ] fumbled
on the 50-yard line [ __ ] through
braves oh yeah that's right he did it
so you talk all this about drew brees i
don't know how i don't know how
somehow you got super hype about new
orleans
and went i bet you win the super bowl
and i said
there's not a chance in hell they win
the football you said really let's bet i
said
okay malik i'll take every other team
but the saints you a
deal i said shoes it's a deal i told you
you bet him
if you win i'll buy you seven that's
what really got me though
because that's a really bad bad bad on
you
that's right that's how i made it yeah
that time made it fair [ __ ] me up
saints win and they were at the time
their third favorite to win the super
bowl yeah
if saints win i'll buy you seven pairs
of shoes mess me up if anybody else wins
you owe me one pair of shoes
that's it saints got lost last night i
sent you a link to the shoes that i want
and then i was texting jay offline like
i feel bad alex awful at better
awful i don't know why you keep going
four grand another one hold on hold on
no hey
so he listen he was like you know what i
feel like he said he listen i feel bad
no shoes i was like man don't feel bad
we got another bet pendant on sunday
i said i'll take the chiefs but patrick
my homeboy has to play no you said
even you said no no no
you said i i go you know patrick holmes
if they do it right he's not going to
play on sunday
there's no way you can get knocked out
like and then get cleared to play
he couldn't stand up yeah he could do
that he was insane if they allow him to
play they're going to do that
they know what's at risk so even if they
allow him to play
there's no way he finishes the game he's
going to finish the game he'll get
knocked out of the game
you know how concussion like he's going
to be so susceptible to get knocked
out we need him for the first half on
the first all you need is a lead with
the uh the
chiefs they don't give up leads now come
on man
you gotta drive down and you gotta win
might get all those bills
that's a big different thing bills are
great and i say
we again again
the first three days 72 hours i'm saying
mcdermott send my boy a jersey
come on [ __ ] that's job 43 what's up
nah it's not bad bad but you said i'll
even i'll even take
even if patrick mahomes doesn't play
i'll bet you they win i said all right
deal what do you want to do shoes you
went yep and i went malik
why don't you give it a few days watch
no you didn't no no no no no hell no
nice cheating he goes
i said espn no you say you have until
wednesday you try to ice me a little bit
your [ __ ] this
he does what he is he goes he goes i was
like i don't know if my home's just
playing and jay intervened he was like
malik
calm down i wouldn't take that bet let's
see what my home does right we gotta
know
he goes he goes nah you have until
wednesday i said
sunday he was like yeah but he
hit the deadline that jay was like hold
on but we were talking about vegas rules
vegas lines you don't place the bet
until the game starts like that's when
the deadline is so i have until sunday
to make the better night that's fair
that's fair hey
why do you bully him thank you you see
what he does you know he's bad at
betting no no
no i know that's why i stopped that is
he bullied no he is or is he trying to
help you no no he's not trying to you
know
money but look here's the thing this is
what he does though and i hate this like
right now i'm just chasing the money
i'm looking for any and everything that
like get even because he doesn't listen
he says he's undefeated but he's really
not i know i've never lost
he has you guys yeah i've never lost you
gotta l england
not to our group i haven't but you know
what it is you take bets that are safe i
take risk
what i mean yeah it makes sense but it's
bad
it's really bad that's a bad thing don't
do that man
it's an upset waiting to happen well
i'll give you this sunday to make that
yeah exactly
all right all we need is what are we in
the back shoes
you already have all the jerseys i mean
what are you i'm all set yeah
it's really just about hurting you at
this point i don't need shoes
it's mainly about your pride here's the
shoe it's not cheap shoes that he gets
he wants
for kids no
he's not asking for filos
he loves us when i get off stage with
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son